just got a reply to my agent here over
email
well you gonna job offer you had to
teach English in Korea where were we
we're in the middle of your fake podcast
look David I'm happy to interview you
but this isn't exactly the networking
opportunity I had it originally hoped
for what are you talking about this is
as good as it gets in Hollywood a
podcast and a storage unit you get any
bigger than this it's gonna be drugs
boating accident Buddhism you don't want
any of that I don't know what my college
adviser is gonna think about this
internship college adviser who cares
college is a waste of time
I mean I don't even play colleges
anymore
you want to know why why funny story oh
Jesus you can't just come in here dude I
just booked a two thousand dollar
college gig on eat so I can't do it you
Muslims need to loosen up look at the
Christians on their holiest day they got
a rabbit handing out candy and the Jews
I get your point but I just fasted for a
whole month so I have to eat with my
family well let me see if I can clear my
schedule yeah I could squeeze it in but
what if there's somebody better what are
you talking about I love college the
late-night parties allowed music the
wild sex I mean those are things I
report to the cops all the time
oh hey millennial huh can you tell me
where the student union is let me ask
you a question do you agree there's too
much income inequality these days no I
think there should be more I either want
to be filthy rich or dirt poor scheming
with criminals not try than a Honda Wow
you really don't understand what it's
like to be poor maybe try listening to
their story for once I do every night
involuntarily
I need thicker windows okay okay there's
no point in talking to you because
you're clearly just a brainwashed
capitalist shill okay
socialists I get it let me tell you
something MTV tried 25 years to get
seven strangers to live in a house
together it doesn't work off
you yeah
hi do you have a moment for sensible gun
control I don't know I kind of like guns
I mean people using them protect against
tyranny wait tyranny seriously
government's not gonna come for you you
liberals say that now let me tell you if
Trump gets elected you're gonna have
Rachel Maddow on MSNBC showing people
how to sawfish shotgun okay you did
ya me ever wants to me now
what's the story okay hey can you tell
me where that relax pal we're here
protesting the lack of diversity on
campus there's too many white males like
you me Jesus pal you make me look like
Nat King Cole I'm an ally of the people
of African descent and all other
minority groups it's important to use
our white mouse status to help all
african-american groups and other people
of color even undocumented immigrants
all right well I agree you know I'm Pro
immigrant I mean that said I think you
should be a fourth-generation American
to legally own stereo equipment are you
kidding me man get out of here
be gone white devil
in the end I had to cancel the show
because of the boycott